hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and
this is my 120 remember that you know
120 seconds of my thoughts I want to
talk to you guys about what I've been
giving a lot of thought to I just want
on this amazing to we tripped and I hit
me exactly what I'm about what I want to
accomplish and I'm hoping you could take
a little snippet from this and realize
the power in it I've come to realize
through my two-week journey of 10
flights over 12 days and through my
interactions and my overwhelming pneus
of emails interaction that I've come to
realize it's the way I score life that
is giving me this competitive advantage
and bringing me all this happiness then
let me break it down to what I mean is
it's not about how many viewers you have
or analytics or the click throughs or
the cprs or CPMs are all that crap it's
really not about your bank account
either it's about the connections you
make with humans it's why you guys are
all watching this video in the first
place this internet thing is connecting
us in a way that's never been connected
before and so what I realized is I'm not
collecting monies or baseball cards
anymore I'm collecting relationships and
that is my mission my new mission in
life and I know it's not scalable but
I'm gonna fight like act like everything
else is to meet every single person on
earth silly yes my goal yes I think what
people realize is and what I've always
realized and I think I hope you can come
to realize is when you're laying on your
deathbed and I hate to get that grim but
this is how I live my life when you're
laying on your deathbed I just don't
think you're gonna care about the
dollars and cents of your bank account
or what you're leaving in your will it's
going to be about the memories right and
I don't think it's about the memories of
you on your yacht with like six models
whether they're male or female right pop
and crystal I don't I think it's gonna
be out the genuine connections you've
made through your life and though it may
even be for a minute or two when I go to
a wine bar like corkscrew in Texas or
when I do something at sea conference
and talk to everybody afterwards it's
not about anything other than that
minute or two of quality time and you
can have it in a minute or two that is
really driving me the rooting for the
other people that come to me and saying
I love what you're doing i'm going to do
this the sand castle guy the lawyer that
I just talked to that want to be
america's lawyer the dr phil rooting for
those people touching those people
meaning those people i think is
imperative and so my new mission in life
is to meet every single person i can and
spend a minute or two and the new way i
am going to count score in life is going
to be about personal connections not
about the decimal points in my bank
account have a great day